all right so we got john and malia over
and they're gonna do something super
nice
and make us a seafood boil is what it's
called
i'm really excited
because
looking at the ingredients it already
looks delicious how do you guys come up
with this recipe
um so his brother's wife yeah lisa lisa
she
used to work at bowling crab
i like where this is going so we we uh
did like a video with her where we were
streaming this whole thing yeah so she
was giving us all the recipes for it and
then she tweaked it though
oh she tweaked it yeah she tweaked it
and then we tweaked
it the next time she made it and then
yeah because you saw tweakers
oh perfect tweakers
well i mean we made this like a few
times for different groups of our
friends yeah it just became something
that we enjoyed making and we knew it
was kind of like hands-on family style
something to just like get really really
uh uh intimate you know with everybody
yeah we all get to just eat from like
the center of the table yeah yeah
it just felt really really nice and uh
uh we got to connect at a different
level but this was something that it's
not high level by any means to create
but it is just like
everyone if they want to can be a part
of the process or they can just be there
when to enjoy the food it's all all good
because it's no stress on anyone oh yeah
yeah so
so what ingredients do we need to make
something like this because i see a ton
of stuff
i'm gonna start off with the protein
sources look at that locally caught
shrimp nevada yeah yeah
and then we also have uh where's all
this stuff where's our sausage just go
through them
okay well we have king crab like yeah
look at those
and then in there it's a secret it's a
secret weapon okay lots of tails yes
oh there was a secret
all right
and then uh the other one is in the
fridge it's just sausage oh i love
sausage too
sausage yeah we got sausage
wait no no no no no we don't we don't we
don't
we insta-carted everything and then
whatever was missing they just oh
yeah so how important is this how can we
have three of these guys um actually
we were supposed to only have two i
didn't because i thought they were small
bags yeah but when i opened them they're
like these big bags oh yeah what's the
main flavoring ingredient for like a
seafood bowl is it this
[Music]
oh do you use the whole thing or just a
couple no we don't use the whole thing
we use this for the boil the water
itself and then we also use it for the
seasoning so old bay is the main one
and then this is another one of the main
ones another one of the main ones and
then we also have oh don't don't play
this is this is a big main one
which one you can play around with which
one we got cayenne bailey's pepper sea
salt and then we also have paprika but i
don't know where it is it's in there
somewhere yeah i guarantee it's in there
yeah we have paprika yeah you can play
around with that to see how spicy you'd
like it yeah and then what about this
what's this this is the cajun seasoning
and then i also see three minced garlics
over there what is that all about well
these ones we're not going to use those
we're not no we have a real garlic here
oh
okay because the first location only had
this much or or yeah like like four
yeah bart and one bar
like six more just in case yeah and then
so because they only had a few they
picked up this instead so we brought
over like that's not what we asked for
oh i see i see gotcha
a little bit sour yeah that one's kind
of tasty it kind of tastes good oh and
we also got lemon
zest meanwhile we have this screaming
child for no reason what's going on you
crazy
baby no put him on the couch you do have
a sleeping baby you're gonna wake up the
baby
okay
i'm gonna keep you hey you're gonna
you're gonna wake up the baby dude
i told him he's saying helping me while
he's attacking me
oh my god there we go again
there we go again he's saying help me
what happened
you didn't help him because no one's
helping him even though he's the one
attacking joe i was pushing him away
we need those tears for the seafood boil
it's gonna add flavor
so basically you
to load up a glass jar or something that
can uh sustain a lot of impact yeah
not like a plastic jar because then
that'll kind of rebound and bounce off
the walls yeah but you put it on
something like this what kind of
technique is this i don't know how'd you
learn how did you learn this uh the
homies kane and johnny actually showed
up to us and we picked it up and kept it
with us ever since we made it from a
korean really we live from mexico
koreans love garlic they do yeah
whoa okay
all right all right
and then
wow there's a lot of blood going to my
head
and then it peels
it peels off
all this stuff that you would kind of do
about by yourself on your hands
the only method i know but only it only
works if you mince is if you just take
one of these guys and use the flat side
of a blade right oh you're smashing it
right and you just peel it after it yeah
yeah i think this is like to do many of
them at the same time yeah it's way
faster it could be could be but it's
like extremely easy but i guess you'd
have to do it a lot longer than i just
did because
i'm still having to peel them with my
hands
oh the whole peel's supposed to come off
yeah you do it so hard that they just
like shatter all the shells oh wow okay
yeah so apparently i'm just weak
back to the gym yeah
all right joe has a better technique i
think better or maybe better apparatus i
think the apparatus
okay
damn that's it
i don't know
hold on let me try this one
we're
[Laughter]
no no
[Laughter]
it works at home with my metal ones
yeah i don't know why but it's the it's
the material yeah it's like
wait the [ __ ] is this dude
oh man yeah let's go
get some more do some more some more
well you didn't like that you didn't
like that you didn't like it
oh shoot
yeah
oh my god i'm gonna use this for
everything now does anyone else need any
garlic
stuff
the whole family is helping now
watch out duty you got it let me know
when you need it
watch your hands
all right what's the step now for now
we've uh we've let them boil with uh the
seasoning that we we you know we spiced
it up our own way uh and uh now we're
just like parting out all the things
that we want as edibles yeah into a bowl
so it can like sit and be ready for us
to go yeah and uh and then we're also on
the side as you can see malia is working
on
what is that is that garlic butter
yeah look how much butter is in this
look how big that is what butter yeah
so what do you what do you put does he
put this in here no no no we put this on
the parchment paper and then load it up
with all the other seafood after we boil
those as well so you boil the veggies
first and then boil the seafood after
yes sir
keep it taste longer oh it's
vegetables we got the corn and potatoes
that we put in first yeah um
and then uh yeah next is gonna be all of
our proteins man hell yeah protein
goes through
all right work goes through nice and
smooth you know brother okay let's see
[Music]
what's that feel to you
i don't know what i'm feeling for
baby
where's my where's my bitten milk yeah
oh i gotta i got hunted look at my
bitten potato
yeah bit one already you better want to
put it back in yes perfect
there it
is yeah
you poke it
okay
i think
it'll be cooked a little more what do
you think i gotta bite it
it's hot it's a potato it's done
hear nothing problems
so we're gonna tape the paper we're
gonna do the same thing and we're gonna
do it family style we're just gonna dump
all the stuff in the middle and then
that way the cleanup is easy because we
just
roll it up together
trash it all
maybe a little wipe wipe down you know
in case anything slips through the
cracks but
more or less no plates no hands no your
eyes overlapping a little bit
a little bit maybe save the middle too
oh no no no if you take the middle then
we have to flip the thing upside down
because you don't want to eat on tape
you'd rather not eat okay
so why is there
food on the table
is there a specific order
um we went with the lobster first
because they take longer to cook yeah
and then these are pretty much done
but we wanted to make room for the
shrimp and the shrimp is super fast oh
cause we have a ton of it huh yeah we
have a lot of shrimp i see
this is our main protein oh it's done
ready
as soon as it's red i feel like
this would be delicious to drink
i mean you could drop it yeah like make
it for something yeah
all right wait don't stop it
oh
peanut butter
oh
[Music]
i mean i'm in the middle i mean i'm into
i'm already in the groove yeah just dump
it baby just dump it
shoot all right
you said y'all like garlic so we deliver
we're gonna be staying
cheers
[Applause]
look at all this alcohol here this is
crazy
wow
have you tried lemon coke
that's how they do it in hong kong yeah
it's like a really popular thing hong
kong style
make sure so like the way that the sauce
is lathered up in here yeah exactly like
that you want to get it everywhere all
in there
that's good yeah
don't be shy because there's a lot of
garlic in here so like feels like free
to like grab with the garlic or whatever
oh my god
oh shoot you guys are wearing white too
go i know
the pro my turn got a little bit of the
butter action okay a little bit of the
garlic action dip it in the
lemonade
i haven't even done that yet lemonade
it's all right dude it really turned me
on no no please stop there we go
nah never mind okay what is going on
dude trust me trust me look at that
oh damn what's your finger doing dude
i called you i told you i told you to
live the good life the valentine's day
valentine's edition yeah
tomorrow
he's not into valentine's day
he's like no girls very very good thank
you guys for watching shout out to john
and malia
mom and dad
oh thank you guys for having us no way
no way
to joe and hannah for just existing
[Laughter]